hello there reject nation we're going to
watch the penultimate episode of part
one of the not real finale upcoming for
stranger things episode
six season four you know yep all right
guys listen full length watch along
should be single with the time code for
super sexy rejects thank you all who
have been joining us over there patreon
is what i'm talking about full length
watch did i say that already yeah we got
a whole bunch of things over there with
the same tier you get the option for
reaction highlights and watch along
included all right yeah also subscribing
click that notification bell to get
notified when our reaction for the
finale is up if you don't want to any of
those options least you can do is leave
a like wouldn't that be kind of you i
think that'd be very kind of you and
thanks to the people at prepper for
helping us edit down these highlights
simply would not be able to get this all
done while in the middle of moving and
covering a bunch of other things thank
you guys and lastly thank all of you for
just being here um
i like most of you and i love
some of you but i loathe a very small
percentage of you
and i don't see you in your dreams
tonight
[Music]
eddie is a vessel
just a vessel
for satan
[Music]
he's made a pact with the devil now he
has his powers
who would have thought it
makes sense him yeah
satanic panic
jason's down there for the point of that
vector
i'm hungry
dr brendan's special little pet has gone
rogue again and he and his lackeys are
now seeking to cover it up
i really think he doesn't know be safer
that way
did he get some kind of special pen your
abilities
are still in here
you just need to remember
you're far too uncomfortably intimidated
everything that took place in my lab is
captured on videotape
and we will watch them all
you have demons in your past
that is why we must proceed carefully
one memory at a time
if we go too fast
i'm afraid you could become lost in the
darkness
maybe uh
lunging her into these experiences
without any heads up was not a good idea
then brother
now it's the only way to learn to swim
where are you skull rock uh do you know
it oh yeah that's near cornwallis and
garrett yeah yeah i know i know what
that is
hold tight we're coming we're coming
why doesn't vector want anything to do
with him
you don't feel guilty about [ __ ]
yes
not even this experience
no trauma at all
oh
hey
is susie here
ow son of rambo
uh excuse me
hey we're looking for susie
can you
not see
that we are filming shh it is code
you are gonna make it one day kid you
see are you making sure to get that
selfish little four-eyed [ __ ] a nice
little chef for me i'm
absolutely
eating i
breakfast club
susie yeah
we're dustin's friends yeah we really
need your help
[Applause]
[Music]
for dusty bun
that
was
surprisingly wacky
yep any luck with our friend
what do you think
damn even he survived that he wasn't
even buckled up yeah
like a throne
the thing is we don't need to kill you
we can just leave you here because
there's nothing for miles i saw tracks
cracks in the woods yuri bears your
favorite
shall we fly out of here little bird
ah
[Laughter]
you really didn't think about that yeah
come on dude that's probably my first
thought you're a cut throat you should
have thought
we will need to reach prison by night
fall if you hope to save your friend
music is on
point yup
gotta buy that sounds
we earned this and nothing bad will
happen this could be about something
this is not our final meal
you need to do
isn't it right cursed one
you'd have lost your spirit to live yeah
no something like that
you know why they feed captive predators
live prey
because if they don't the predator gets
bored
and it stops eating it needs the thrill
of the hunt
throw the slaughter
so eat up boys
enjoy
this is your last meal
[Music]
but you know how to beat a demogorgon
yeah train em hop everybody eat really
shitty so the demogorgon gets a tummy
ache do you remember the day a strange
woman came to see you
this would have been when eight was
still here
eight
eight
she was calling a name to you
that
was your mother
mama is dead
she died making me and who told you that
this place
and the people here
are not what you think
good morning children
interesting
[Music]
that's vector
yes
that's right origins
this little white suit
everyone backing the targets
has something in their life
something that's hurting them
haunting them and that they feel like
they can't open up about it all would
that be so terrible for me to wish with
happiness for my friends you think i'm
not happy i'm sure you are it's just the
other day in the library i mentioned
jonathan you sort of flinched or winced
or something flinch or
wince so does that make us friends as in
officially uh
yeah
i i i mean right
right
i feel like you would decide that if
anybody dancy
we will be enforcing a strict curfew
that's your solution hide from him we're
already doing that it's been days
evil dies tonight
for 40 years any months terrorizing this
town
these murders are ritualistic sacrifices
they call themselves hellfire that's
[ __ ] the hellfire isn't a cause it's
a club for nerds a harmless club that's
what they want you to think
but it's a lie
oh
christ oh man this is crazy
but overcome evil with good and god
knows there's good in this town so much
good it's in this room
it's in this room right here right now
what's murder
and safe hawkins together
[Music]
wait was this just
[Music]
permanent record i just wonder why they
were cutting rat to the parents so much
i dial into this computer and find a
location and then nina project is the
code name for
a video game well no it's not just a
video game it's a video game console
it's basically america's answer to
nintendo america nintendo
i would do anything for dusty bun but
i'm afraid there's been an unfortunate
development
after changing dusty's grade i was
racked with the most awful
no
my soul was tortured and he wrenched a
confession out of me
not only was i breaking the law i was
dating an agnostic and i agnostic
after learning the terrible truth
he confiscated my computer and father is
not one to change his mind i'm as likely
to see it again as i am my poor dusty
bun the one time i don't wear my yellow
hat
[Music]
that's terrifying that is absolutely
terrifying to be a parent in this
situation jesus
that sucks our children are not
murderers ted don't put words in my
mouth
see if she doesn't twist my words you're
the police
we we were just there you guys know
they've been involved in crazy fbi [ __ ]
before now we just need to sneak into
his lair in the upside down and drive a
stake through his heart if he even has a
heart a stake is he like a vamp is he a
vampire
this compass worked correctly when we
left the wheelers but it started to slip
the further east we went now
it's way off when i was leading us here
i wasn't wrong
the compass was so you're using faulty
equipment dude you're still wrong oh my
god
in the presence of a stronger
electromagnetic field the needle will
deflect towards that power so either
there's some super big magnet around
here or there's a gate
what if
somehow there's another gate a gate that
we don't know about it has to be smaller
way less powerful snack size game
fun size something is causing this
disturbance and the last time we've seen
anything like it it was a gate and i
hope it is because then we'd have a way
to vechna and a shot at freeing max from
this curse but what do we do when you
get in there yeah you chop his head off
shoot him
the last person standing in their circle
will get to spend an extra hour of free
time
in the rainbow room
yay
begin
[Music]
ouch wow
[Music]
take one of those why a movies yeah
it looks like a divergent
it's pretty wild
[Music]
hold on mod 11 come on found his
strength and a memory from his past
something that made him sad but also
angry
do you maybe have a memory like that
[Music]
yes ma'am
[Music]
very good 11.
[Music]
oh well
it looks like we have a new winner
number two more like it you don't want
to keep talking [ __ ] you are [ __ ]
you see that grace people over there
that is your house it looks like a
church
let's see what miracles it holds yes
drago
half he dies
where's the rocky references
just have stallone run by in the
background
with a log in tow
we don't have time for show and tell we
need to get going she's always this
bossy
he heard
her
keys map
let's go
murray
i'd find that suspicious which is why
from here on out you're gonna be murray
and i'm gonna be yuri
don't worry
[Music]
it's a silent roll
you better have the most authentic
russian accent murray yeah for the love
of christ murray
you don't know that you're the reason
why we're in here you're gonna die today
your son is
oh
nice there we go yes
prison break
come on guys fight the guards seriously
read the roof
please tell me you snatched a key or
some [ __ ] we call it a demogorgon i
don't know how they got it here what the
hell they're doing with it
i said about it is true
except it has one weakness
baseball bets
so i figure if we want a shot of killing
this thing
we need some fuel
have any thumb
to light it with
[Music]
a smoking guard nice man so you asked me
if it was worth it
answer your question
[Music]
yeah
i think it was worth it
crazy american
i hope you guys got this son
cornelius
cornelius
i want a cornelius spin-off oh holy heck
you did it hold your applause i don't
see an address
cornelius
i'm running the ip through a geolocation
software basically a form of data mining
[Music]
if you know anything about computers
comment below with plausibility
[Laughter]
incredible
just incredible and father
your terror i look genuine
that kid is my favorite
so dumb but
these kids are gonna drive me in the
loony [ __ ]
hi father you look like you need a nap
i'm banging all these guys father
my dude
the devil's lettuce
no sign of them though skull rock yeah
and that make house play and it's also a
stone's throw from lovers lake the hell
they want to go back there for
one way to find out
i think we're getting close
watch your step big guy
ah
okay you guys stay here with max
keep an eye out for truffle you keep an
eye out
it's my goddamn theory you heard nancy
who put her in charge i did
compass
oh dustin
i mean not bringing max is good but not
bringing dustin
jeez
you shouldn't be wandering the halls
cool
you are
weak
empathetic
i was holding back
you do that before everyone
see you later
a roller skating shoe
oh jesus
super power bullies
[Applause]
oh you [ __ ] tell papa we did this
we will kill you oh you [ __ ]
deep breaths
take deep breaths
you did well eleven you did very well i
killed them tonight papa
[Music]
seem like they get to a point where they
try to kill you man
somebody's got to go down there and
check this thing out unless one of you
so he can top being a hawkins high swim
co-captain and a certified lifeguard for
three years now
wow
drink it in
when steve gets so hairy right i keep
telling him he needs to tame that jungle
but he claims the ladies dig it let me
see
what
[Music]
steve's still got it
steve
be careful
you're hot let's basically and i love
you
i don't care what you're captain of that
[ __ ] is
so cold and murky
he definitely found it steve has
incredible lung capacity
where are we at wheeler
closing in on a minute okay
no wait
steve come on
oh nice [ __ ]
now it's gonna be e.t
so eerie you better swim up now
you already found it stop
go up
no
there's no need to look some more
grab that flashlight no
pull them up we're gonna have a lord of
the rings fight here
dustin you're a goddamn einstein
cops
[ __ ] i can't let him find eddie
or are you guys okay yeah
over here
get out of there please he's pretty damn
good oh my god
don't no
steve
what the hell was that man
she's going in after him
oh my god
[Music]
what is happening
just
wait here
[Music]
because i have no idea what you're
swimming towards you can't see anything
maybe they can follow the flashlights
harry steve there's steve
hey best head hair best chester
[Music]
no
no
ow
oh my god no way
of course
okay of course i'll probably be fine
yeah yeah
nah there's a chance steve can die i
don't want steve to die i would be so
saddened [ __ ]
killer season whoo that's intense all
right let's talk about it all right well
i mean the the thing about this episode
that i think is very different this
question will probably be pretty short
is that the other episodes what i've
really admired about season
seven so she's succeeded
you know
it might as well be with the length of
these
by the way it's gonna be a two part for
the next episode yes
season four season four so far is that
each episode has truly felt like a
complete chapter
and you know what i mean
like it's all felt like a complete
episode where it's the first time i'm
watching stranger things really feeling
like this could have been a week-to-week
show
uh whereas the prior seasons have been
very like the it's a bin show yeah yeah
for sure and uh the the way these
episodes have been done where this is
not a a slight added because i'm used to
stranger things being the way it is is
that this one really feels like a major
setup for the next episode yes it does
yeah it's still a great episode but it's
still it still feels like more of a
setup episode yeah it feels the most
like a kind of transitional or
connective piece rather than its own
contained
chapter yeah like you said i think
that's a good way to put that but it's
still great there's still some great
stuff still super grippy and something
about you were saying before was like
you've been waiting for steve to have
something that's more just like his own
thing or something a little more juicy
and he gets it here oh yeah i mean
they heard me and now i'm afraid for
steve's life but uh yeah you know he
wanted him to have something more meaty
to chew on and now he's the meat being
chewed on that's right man be careful
what you wish for monkey's paw season
yeah dumb ass yeah yeah i put steve
never forgive myself
but yeah it's only for him to touch it
come on you clearly found it it's either
lava or the upside down come on man yes
and you're not anywhere near hope
yeah yeah yeah yeah
don't ever turn your back on a portal no
matter what size fun king or otherwise
but yeah i mean
like they are good at every time i feel
like we bring up something usually the
next episode has something to say about
that and i am
you know excited to see
how the four of them handled this
together because you know it seems like
they are going to have dustin and lucas
and max at least separated with the cops
and then you'll have our you know team
cast our older team cast in the upside
down with vecna having to at least sort
out
you know whatever the next part is true
you know the mid-season finale leave off
part is well i mean the satanic panic
quality of this was really gripping you
know as kind of predictable as it would
be that i think his name is jason
yeah the the basketball player i am
jason speech guy speech guy
basketball save the speech man no matter
how much pain i'm in
i always got
i've got a rousing five minutes for you
no matter how traumatized i am i was
born for public speaking
he really is that character yep he's the
great you can see why he's the top of
the first scene is a big speech to the
auditorium second see that and then
when chrissy's dead
speech to the basketball team that's
speech to the community of hawkins he's
gonna run for senator or something i'll
tell you you can motivate man yeah um
because
yeah i've been capturing that era of
satanic panic is fascinating
i thought it would just be solely
strictly to find eddie i think it does
raise the stakes a lot when you
include the the rest of the kids you
know
like the the fear of the situation
really rose when you're looking at the
parents
and you're seeing the worry in them the
fear in them of like my children i think
that's why the fear was so good it's
like they might kill my kids mm-hmm you
know that's a really scary feeling and
knowing
i mean it's like
i feel like mike and dustin will
probably be alive but
sure uh but i think that fear is a very
real feeling especially just knowing the
kind of sick world
like i'm talking like a real world like
we live in a messed up world and
you know that like people got to this
point they would do it so i think
especially now especially now yeah so
emitting that fear in here i think is a
very like kind of a real feeling to
latch on to
um
and uh i appreciate that because i mean
i said a couple episodes ago that this
this season has had us has captured this
80s world of supernatural horror and
serial killer horror and while it's way
more supernatural horror
um than serial killer horror there's
still like these undertones that really
grip at that
you know what i mean they latch into
that and i think that's a quality of it
i think that's why the satanic panic
motif works so well is because it does
represent this convergence of the very
human you know horrific serial killer
kind of
capability mixed with the belief that
yeah you are some kind of conduit for
otherworldly malevolent spirits and and
you know as much as we were joking about
it last time about jason is basically
coming to the conclusion that eddie is
some kind of conduit for that you know
it it
it it does kind of track well in that
80s kind of heightened sense it's
definitely through today you'd be like
you're a [ __ ] idiot yeah you'd be
like come on something is clearly going
on just dungeons and dragons yeah
guys but no in the 80s oh most
definitely well and they make that point
of touching on like dustin's an agnostic
you know to clue you into it's also a
much more religious time i mean i still
remember what it's like growing up as a
90s as a kid yeah and and being you know
being told like that's satanic yeah i
still know
now it's like
i mean there's still those parts of the
world they're getting wrong there's a
lot of that out there but at least in
the california world i grew up in now
there's way less of that where now
people gawk at that and roll their eyes
like you're come on you're being silly
yeah um but no i still definitely
remember what it was like when that was
kind of a norm of being like that's
satanic that's evil that's perverse you
know yes
it's taboo and it's dark and it's
something yeah you shouldn't even guess
it's it's forbidden yeah yeah yeah like
going a hot topic was some scary thing
when there's like a golf yeah you see
like a heavy metal shirt with some
vaguely religious iconography and you're
like oh god jesus is gonna send me to
hell for looking at this
um so capturing that is is cool and and
uh
it is
that when they went with neckbeard guy
is the one to be like come on what are
you all waiting for
you know i was like
doing commentary but it is small town
you can it looks like a lot of people
who will be in hawkins well and it is
there it's that like what are you gonna
do arrest all of us yeah we're tired of
uh listening to you basically placate us
and uh yeah i mean i think that it's
funny i liked getting to see all of the
main kids parents together taking this
in and i could have not that it's a
gripe you know there's a lot to do but i
could have almost used like
a little bit more of a scene where
they're all in the house together
because like that does it struck me it's
like we see these kids so much we saw a
lot of mike's family before
but uh
you know i think it's it's
i don't know there's something that
struck me about that i almost wish we
could have gotten a little more of that
perspective of the terror of finding out
like all of our kids are implicated in
this hellfire club what does that mean
to us given everything we've just
witnessed a town hall and we know that
our kids have been wrapped up in
freaking government [ __ ] before now yeah
and so like what would be all of their
responses to that uh but
even such i mean
yeah everything going on at hawkins is
really fun and engaging and it's
interesting the way they've drawn the
tone this season because obviously they
have the various 80s era slasher horror
you know supernatural movies they're
drawing from but there is this
locked-in
kind of goofiness or or there's
during certain scenes you know the
switch back to being more mad cap or
more comedy like at the house that um
dustin's girlfriend whose name i'm now
blanking on lives at susie do you copy
susie there you go yeah like things like
that or things like joyce and murray
like
lean more broadly towards comedy than
i feel like maybe we did in the past so
it's an interesting kind of tonal
evolution they've got on
well this susie part was
at first like
at first so this is too much for me
it's like this is like really
really coming on strong you're coming on
strong with your comedy
this house is in a whole other universe
let's dial back the copy a little bit
but then yeah but then it did feel that
way of like i don't know what this is
right now stepped into like a whimsical
family movie about a bunch of colorful
orphans um
and then uh but that but i did like the
proceeding bit with the dad and stuff
like sorry kyle i was like
stop raising this crack me up
before i was like this is a lot but yeah
it's like it overwhelms you at first but
when they all pay off at the end it's it
is kind of satisfying you know
i do think that like yeah mike and will
and jonathan that like that camp has
just not been
super interesting
no like companies like even their plot
development is like they're just looking
for eleven and we see we're already
clued into everything eleven's doing and
we're not even included we know what
eleven's doing and i'm like what are
they gonna do when they get there yeah
it's like i feel like they they they
space that plotline out literally with
geography because it's gonna take a
while to drive from place to place in
the van and so it is like every time we
check in with them per episode i feel
like they get one beat ahead
i think
i i'm hoping the payoff is rewarding
yeah because right now the current
journey is not the most engaging to me
on what they're doing yeah yeah so maybe
maybe for them to do yeah maybe when the
payoff happens the journey will then be
rewarding yeah um you know because i've
had that happen with like we're watching
stranger things like some stuff i didn't
really care for as much but knowing
where it was going suddenly made it like
more enjoyable because i knew what the
payoff would be yeah um so kind of hope
that's the same thing because yeah right
now i'm like
hey you guys are just kind of the
whatever part of the show
it's fun to check in with you guys but
it doesn't feel as vital that we're here
right now
yeah that's the least interesting part
to me yeah yeah and i mean the russian
stuff is cool i mean the the prison is
good
hopper and yeah i love hopper and uh and
the guard guy
yeah even that kind of carried like a
religious undertone um
in some way like we're going into the
fiery gates of hell in some way yeah
it's almost like a sort of religious
table setting last supper yeah it pulls
you back to being like they're almost
like gladiators in some kind of ancient
arena that yeah are going to be
sacrificed to you know a beast but also
to appease the gods of some yeah you
know otherworldly realm well i like that
like hopper was like kind of willing to
quit but um like give it all up
but i think he came to that final like
laughing
ironic laughing point of enough is
enough for his like but i won't die at
the hands of a demographic yeah it's
like any of these circumstances but no
uh-uh if there's one thing i refuse to
die for it is this it is this great yeah
no not after everything in these last
three seasons yeah that's that's why i i
think that was great and like watching
this kind of natural
bond that's forming between him and the
i don't know that other guy's name i
read his name tag every time and i still
haven't committed it to jock and hagon
that's the name enzo enzo there you go
yeah yeah yeah there you go
yeah yeah i like him a lot and
and they have great character casting
for all these different russian
prisoners but um
but the 11 stuff is probably the most
interesting stuff yeah that's that's
eerie sorry the diamond sinister yeah we
got a
bunch of some other things to shoot
right now um but yeah the
the last thing is probably the biggest
thing everything with 11. you know we're
unpacking the rainbow room and it dawned
on me for some reason it's the first
time really dawned on me like
oh we're really
we're really here
like we're really dealing with
the upbringing and the training process
with brenner and everything like this is
the first time we're it's not just some
mysterious
look yeah yeah like we're just doing
full-on scenes
oh wow we're actually unpacking this uh
truly it's just so natural the way we're
doing it and it flows so well and still
keeps that air of mystery
that
um it didn't
truly dawn on me of like because usually
just like quick flashes or little
memories or some type of you know when
she's in the
the uh what are those tanks called
sensory defensive tester deprivation
tank you know like it's usually not just
a clear cut let's just sit here with
seeing what the lifestyle was
it's a really conscientious way to do
your like prequel slash flashbacks but
also keep them very relevant to the
current progression of the character and
watching how
her upbringing with the kids there
mirrors
her
you know when she's trying to start a
new life as jane hopper in california
and you know like the path that she went
down like oh yeah you could have
probably killed like angela oh yeah
i exploded her on the spot probably and
and that makes me curious like i've been
really curious as to what the payoff is
going to be with
her as it relates to everything else
because there are motifs they use in 11
story that match what goes on in hawkins
with vecna with you know the lights
flickering and
clearly they've highlighted that she has
a very traumatic and guilt-riddled past
with this experience in particular so i
feel like it in the next episode or or
sometime soon those things have to
collide in some way
but either way like the glimpse has been
terrific
yeah yeah like it could it could easily
not be and i think they've used it
really really conscientiously amen to
that sister amen
all right guys
um
let's uh
let's end this we got one more episode
to go that's gonna be a two-parter yeah
that's gonna be a two-parter in fact
[Music]